and cultures a columnist and author of
audio's america as well as many other
books and she joins us tonight and
thanks for coming on so you have a great
piece on Lindsey Graham who've won the
2016 Republican nomination as you know
and as a result of that has a right to
impose his immigration views in the
country how did that work first I want
to say boy Donald Trump is right these
dreamers are fabulous they're great
they're fantastic I can't wait for them
to be our fellow citizens and yeah I
mean I think everybody's wondering where
did the Lindsey Graham come from who
nominated him to be negotiating this he
ran for president he got literally zero
votes was the first and and most vicious
in attacking Donald Trump the candidate
so how is it that he is the one in this
why does he have a seat at the table at
all on immigration negotiations much
less you know he's the leader of what
the Republicans stand for and you know
as I say in my column it does make a any
any normal observer think the fixes in Y
or other Republican senators allowing
this if it had been back during the Iraq
war Republicans wouldn't have allowed
anti-war Republican Chuck Hale Hagel to
go and you know he represents our views
on the war we're gonna send him in no
they'd say no not him don't talk to him
why are the media talking to him why is
the president talking damn he doesn't
represent us but the donors want the
cheap labor I mean the one thing Tucker
that's going to be fun if we if we lose
this is is watching all of these
short-sighted idiotic businessman try to
do business in a country run by the
likes of Camel Harris and Nancy Pelosi
yeah that will be amusing but sad for
the rest of us so but but if there's a
deeper question about democracy here so
if the public has been clear and poll
after poll about what it wants and what
it doesn't want on the question of
immigration and it went to the trouble
of electing Donald Trump against all
odds and all predictions just to express
that view and it still can't get what it
demonstrable wants an immigration is it
possible for the public to have a say in
this no it's amazing
I mean it is beyond what you just
described I was looking through Nexus
transcripts today the fact that Donald
Trump is president it was utterly
implausible it's like a Hollywood movie
and this isn't the first time I mean you
keep hearing these phony polls being
cited by the media showing that
Americans love dreamers they love them
just like that one you interviewed who
couldn't love her they loved them but
every time they have an actual ballot
every time for twenty years now they
will vote against bail for illegals
against government services for illegals
they'll vote for Donald Trump they'll
vote for English as as as the national
language when they're on this Harvard
poll that just came out shows more
Americans would like zero immigration
than our current immigration policy but
the way they pull off these phony polls
is by I mean I didn't read need to read
Saul Alinsky to know that this is not a
good way to take a poll
they personalize it they say oh do you
want to deport Juanita the maid there
they make it about a specific person no
I want questions like do you want more
or less immigration do you think people
who break the law should be able to
become citizens and start collecting
welfare right away
do you think we should be dumping
millions of low-wage workers on the
country which is going to come back I
mean Trump may think he is he is a
genius and in some ways he is he has an
uncanny sense for what are popular
issues that's why he won you may be able
to roll over the never Trump errs but if
he continues down this line former Trump
errs is going to be a much more
difficult category for him you just
think in a democracy you can't ignore
what people want forever else you're
gonna get a pretty bad backlash I think
and thank you for coming on I appreciate
that